so I'm Matt I work at Numenta but this
is not a new meant to talk this isn't a
software talk either in case you're in
the wrong room I'm gonna be talking
about life and humanity where we've been
and where we're going but first before I
really dive into where we're going I
kind of have to put humanity in a
perspective because we can't solve the
problems that we're facing today by
using the same kind of thinking we used
when we created them so I'm going to do
this by putting humanity in the
perspective of time and space
so space being three-dimensional space
and time as the from the origin of life
all the way up to where we are right now
from genes to brains to memes all the
way to technology so we will start with
space so I'm going to ask you to do
something different but I ask you to
walk through this thought experiment
with me and do a little visualization so
I want you to think of a peppercorn and
this is what we're pepper comes from
it's a very small little hard rock like
object that we grinded a pepper and what
you think about holding a peppercorn in
between your fingertips and how small it
is and looking at it in front of your
face and then I want you to imagine that
that peppercorn is the earth rather that
the earth is the size of a peppercorn so
we're going to view space from this
perspective for a little bit just to put
things in a relative size frame so if
earth were a peppercorn the Sun would be
about the size of a bowling ball and it
would be 26 yards away so if I were
holding the Sun in my hands here and you
were holding a peppercorn it would be
somewhere halfway down the rows down
there and that would be the distance
from the Sun to the earth so light takes
about eight and a half minutes to get
from the Sun to the earth so yeah
obviously I can walk a lot faster than
that at this scale I can move much
faster than the speed of light so out to
the bounds of our solar system Pluto not
the planet Pluto but
celestial object Pluto would be about
the size of a grain of sand or salt
Pluto is about four point four light
hours away from the Sun so at the scale
of Earth is a peppercorn Pluto would be
about half a mile away so relative to
the Peabody Opera House
Pluto would be about halfway to the arch
from here so our whole solar system is
sitting here within walking distance so
I can get down there 10 or 15 minutes
and go take a trip to Pluto so that's
our solar system let's look at our
closest star our closest star is Alpha
Centauri and Alpha Centauri is about 4.4
light-years away from our Sun out the
earth as a peppercorn scale this
translates to a little over four
thousand miles so our whole solar system
is right here within walking distance
and the closest star to our solar system
is a plane trip all the way to Hawaii so
between our solar system and the closest
star to us we've got this massive amount
of empty space so let's continue with
this analogy until it breaks down
completely let's look at another star
just a random star that I grabbed within
our galaxy beta Centauri it's it's right
beside Alpha Centauri but it's not close
to Alpha Centauri at all it's about 400
light years away
so I'm gonna translate that to about 370
1,000 miles
so this star considering that our solar
system is within walking distance our
closest star is in Hawaii this random
star is all the way outside of our
atmosphere and about twice the distance
past the moon and let me just put this
to the proper scale it's more like that
if you look at the planet in the moon
within the proper scale so it's a long
way away now I really wanted to try and
relate to you how far it is from our
planet to the center of the Milky Way
galaxy but I've got a big problem here
because it's about 25,000 light-years
away
and the problem is that human beings
involved with these ten digits and
they're very useful for communication
for counting you can imagine Stone Age
man using them to say there are two
saber-tooth Tigers over there but when
it comes to numbers like 145 quadrillion
927 trillion etc these things don't come
in very handy and this is what we're
good at
we're good our brains are really good at
fast calculations with small numbers and
it's evident but this means nothing to
me this huge number
I cannot compute it doesn't work with
our brains so I can't tell you I can't
really relate how far away it is it's a
really long way away and and the cool
thing is I mean you can look out in the
sky if you go out in the country and see
the band of the Milky Way out there in
the sky and see this massive celestial
object that we are all a part of and you
know we've been inspecting this for
years but it's nice if we can get
outside of this atmosphere because
there's a lot of noise here and inspect
some things you know without all of this
atmospheric noise so let's take a look
at some of the things that we've seen
out there so we've got the Hubble
telescope it's probably all familiar
with the beautiful images that it's
returned to us as a nebula other solar
other galaxies etc but there's one thing
about the Hubble that I want to point
out and it's that at some point in the
1990s some brilliant scientists said hey
look look at that dark spot in the night
sky
what's let's just point the Hubble at
one of the the the most dark spots in
the sky and in space and open the
shutters up for like 10 days and see
what happens what see what we'll see and
it's and the amazing thing is imagine
this this group of scientists having
opened the shutters and just stared into
the darkest spot in space for ten days
waiting to see what kind of picture is
being beamed back in through our
atmosphere
and how amazing it must have been to see
this in the darkest place in space these
are there's over 10,000 celestial
objects in this image most of them are
galaxies we're looking billions and
billions of years into the past here so
I can't even relate to you how far it is
from here to the center of our galaxy
and we just randomly shot out there and
saw tens of thousands of galaxies so
space is really big
we've got super clusters of galaxies we
have an idea of what the structure the
super clusters are we can theorize about
the structure of our universe which is
made up of super clusters and then we
kind of reach a wall because of light
and everything because we can't we don't
know what's out there past that light
comes to us there's a certain point
where we don't get anything the edge of
the observable universe you know maybe
there's just a wall around us who knows
as far as I'm concerned it's infinite to
my brain these numbers don't compute so
this it really feels like we live in an
infinite universe so I kind of wanted to
swap out and dive down from a macro
level of how big space is to a micro
level of how big space is but I'm just
going to talk very briefly about this
because I could dive into it but when
you think about matter and you think
about atoms and the subatomic components
of atoms the space inside of an atom an
atom is almost entirely empty when you
dive down into the size of an atom it's
sort of looks and feels like a celestial
object in some ways but it's mostly
empty space almost entirely empty space
this is almost entirely empty space I am
almost entirely empty space so it's not
just this macro macro feeling of lots
and lots of empty space it's all around
us you're surrounded by mostly empty
space and and to kind of add an
additional point here there's a lot of
interesting things going on at this
micro
as well so so here's a biological
process this is a video from Harvard
that shows some of the inner workings of
human cells so I don't really know
what's going on here but there's a lot
of really crazy stuff going on here
there's there's some enzymes and
proteins and chemical processes
occurring tubules being created and
deconstructed I mean this really what is
this thing here does anyone have any
clue what this is I would like to know
afterwards but it's like walking its
transport obviously from one part of the
cell to another but what is its
objective I mean where does all this
come from and that's one of my big
questions here so if kind of talked
about space how big it is and how big it
is internally inside of each one of us
as well so I'm going to move on and talk
about time and then we'll talk about the
future so the history of life on Earth
started about three and a half billion
years ago and it is we are you can see
that little line over there that's all
of human history and we're kind of at
the right side of it
at the very right edge of it so we
haven't been here a whole long time so
I'm gonna kind of walk through this
three and a half billion years ago on
earth at a very volatile atmosphere and
a good portion of the earth was covered
with this mud which we call the
primordial ooze so I love that term it's
an oozy
and so we it was an inorganic matter and
we have a pretty good idea of what it
was constructed with so just by looking
at other planets in our galaxy how we we
could we can conjecture that there is
some hydrogen's and carbon dioxides just
simple molecules ammonia methane so we
have a good idea of what was there we
know that the atmosphere was volatile so
in the 1950s us Stanley Miller and
Harold gray did an experiment at the
University of Chicago where they took
these elements and they put them inside
of this isolated glass bottle and they
started sparking it
started running electricity through the
thing to see what would happen if we
could see we can recreate the conditions
under which we think life was created an
interesting thing happened just within a
matter of a couple of weeks they started
seeing those simple molecules turn into
more complex molecules turn into organic
compounds and turn into enzymes the
building blocks of life building blocks
of protein the building blocks of life
so we can replicate this we can prove
that this was an environment that was
right for life to occur but the thing
that we're missing is that we need some
type of molecule to somehow come into
existence that can copy itself a
replicating molecule so the occurrence
of a replicating molecule just appearing
inside of this primordial ooze that is
right for life to occur is very very
very low you can kind of equate it to
the chances of one of us winning a major
lottery jackpot which is about 100 won
in a hundred and seventy five million
which is really low but what if you
played the lottery once a week for a
hundred million years you'd win 30 times
the earth had a really long time to play
the lottery before life could start and
it was really big was probably playing
the lottery a lot more in this huge mass
of ooze and it only takes one of these
replicating molecules to appear under
the right conditions where it can start
a process so once this starts once we
have these molecules banging into each
other and suddenly one appears that hat
under the right conditions the right
chemical reactions can use other
resources within its environment to copy
itself it makes copies and those copies
are pre-programmed to make more copies
which make more copies and then we get
some really interesting things going on
because we've got an environment now
with limited resources with one type of
replicating molecule taking up all those
resources we have millions of
replications going on all the
and when this occurs nothing is perfect
so there's gonna be some mistakes when
replication occurs it's gonna be random
mutations when this occurs most of these
are going to be inadequate they're not
going to be able to copy themselves
they're just gonna die or break apart
but some of them very small percentage
of them are going to be a little bit
better at replicating maybe they can use
a different type of resource in place of
one of the others they're more flexible
so this brings in to play different
types of replicating molecules because
if you get a few of these happening and
they start replicating differently now
you've got a different situation where
we've got kind of these different
species of replicating molecules all
competing for the same resources and
we've got natural selection starting at
a molecular level just with these
molecules hundreds of millions of years
pass so in under these conditions a lot
of different things could occur but you
can probably imagine these molecules
getting more and more complex as natural
selection plays out potentially building
membranes around themselves to protect
their precious genetic material and here
the line between replicator and organism
was effectively blurred
nobody can pinpoint when life really
started but it was somewhere along in
this process so these valuable genes are
protected now within some type of
mechanism to interact with their
environments to protect the genetic
material and let's call these things
survival machines at this point this was
a term coined by Richard Dawkins in The
Selfish Gene and it's I think it's a
very apt term Gene's build mechanisms to
help protect them so that their only
goal in life is to copy themselves so
some very basic examples of these things
today is ecoli bacteria it's got a a
membrane around itself its genetic
material is inside it interacts with its
environment it's more successful than
we've been it's been around for hundreds
of millions of years
virus a little more complicated
it's got protrusions interact with the
environment as a membrane protecting
genetic material on to more complicated
survival machines like this for a Souris
it also has a membrane has protrusions
interact with its environment and as
genic material encoded within trillions
and trillions of cells the exact same
genetic material its DNA which is
different from every other organism in
the universe so the rhinoceros has been
pretty successful but surviving up until
we came and start shooting them and it
really was a good thing because everyone
and everything that isn't a stupendous
badass is dead this is the key to
natural selection pat yourself on the
back you stupendous badasses ok so let's
talk about the human survival machine a
little bit so this chart I pulled out of
breaker swells book The Singularity is
near and what it [ __ ] here is
milestones from the beginning of life to
today along the course to humanity
basically so we have things like
multicellular organisms mammals brains
evolving spoken language etc all the way
down to Large Hadron particle
accelerator down to the bottom right
so I've pointed out a few things on here
so I've talked about replicators they
haven't talked about brains yet or
technology or Hayter and particle
accelerators but I'm going to make a
distinction here it's a kind of
separates the point where biological
evolution stops having so much of effect
and technological evolution starts
having more of an effect so I don't know
if you'd notice the scales I didn't
really explain them very well but this
is a logarithmic scale and this is the
linear scale of the same data so as you
can kind of see it takes biology a
really long time to evolve once we get
to the point where brains start
occurring that's kind of the tip of the
curve then things really start happening
but as soon as we've developed
technology
it's off game on one thing I want to
note this this big flat line here it's a
it was kind of interesting to me I
looked into it and that consisted of at
least two and a half billion years of
algae that's it just algae that's how
slow DNA evolved it took a really long
time to get to the next step
we move a lot faster today now you have
this beautiful diverse world with all
these different organisms that we can
enjoy and human beings are the masters
of the planet it's a wonderful place we
have this drive to become one with our
environment and and live symbiotically
with nature and that's great you know
that's that's wonderful but I just want
to take this opportunity to remind you
that from the evolutionary standpoint
nature doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
nature don't care about your family your
homes your livelihoods nature is
unsympathetic nature will destroy
thousands and hundreds of thousands
people and organisms within seconds
nature can be a real [ __ ] it will hail
rain down fire upon our heads but yeah I
know that the polar bears we need to
save them you know the ice is melting
they're all going to die polar bears
will tear your face off and eat it that
is what they have been programmed to do
their genes evolved to kill you and it's
their brains that tell them to kill you
so eventually along this light the the
spectrum of replicators to humans
brains came into being so initially
brands were really just a way to take
some type of sensory input from the
environment and creates adaptive
behaviors so organisms were
pre-programmed if this occurred I'm just
going to do
this other thing and if that works then
it moves on to the next generation
there wasn't much thinking involved but
it allowed organisms to observe the
world and react to it dynamically simple
brains are not intelligent they don't
learn they don't maintain memory but
more complex brains like mammal brains
have this neocortex I hope you all
watched Jeff's talk this morning
so I'm not gonna talk too much about the
brain so but it enables memory storage
the interesting thing about this from my
perspective is if you think about life
as a progression of information systems
and genes information was encoded into
genetic material kind of like firmware
and in brains we have a new mechanism
for storing information that evolved
because of genes and this is much more
flexible it's much more dynamic it it
lets organisms collect and learn
information across the course of their
lifetime and now we have this new
mechanism for information to live to
exist from genes to brains and this
gives rise to kind of the next phase in
this which is memes
so I don't want to spend too much time
on internet memes but it's a good
example because no one person wanted
this to happen nobody planned this
there's no corporation involved here and
a marketing strategy this just happened
we there's no explanation for this ideas
have a have a life of their own there
that I read about the origin of the
aniket are so ridiculous I'm not even
get repeated
there's pop-tarts really but but memes
are really really important
you know the spread of ideas through a
medium of brains
so with once we had brains we had some
ability to start communicating between
organisms once we have the ability to
communicate between organisms memes have
a transportation method to go from one
brain to another so a meme could
originate in one brain and spread
quickly throughout the population so
we're talking about things like myths
legends religions stories poems ideas
practices cultural stuff lots of things
these are all memes these are all things
that no one person or corporation
controls so and it doesn't just go
spatially throughout a population it
evolves down generations if it's passed
down to children and grandchildren so
information now has a new way to be free
it's not confined to genes it's not
confined the individual brains it can
spread throughout whole societies down
generations and it gave rise to
technology because no one individual
brain can come up with technology it
takes groups it takes ideas building
upon ideas let me talk briefly about
technology so I'm going to define this
from the Webster term of an application
of scientific knowledge for practical
purposes so what is the the an instance
of technology that's earliest that we've
ever seen well about 1.8 million years
ago some human hit another rock hit a
rock with another rock and chipped it
and
fashion that it was better to be held in
the hand and we have this apparently
someone found it he thought oh that
looks like an ancient artifact but so
this is the first indication we have of
human technology but we were probably
poking each other with sticks throwing
rocks at each other long before that
which is all technology and today we
have this the particle accelerator I'm
going to talk about it you guys looking
up yourselves it's crazy and it took a
1.8 million years to get from Rock it's
a particle accelerator but when you when
you look at the time frame that I'm
putting this all in that's like a drop
in the bucket that's nothing compared to
two and a half billion years of green
algae this is happening fast we're
surrounded by technology every day it's
everywhere we're totally dependent on it
we assume that it's always going to be
there we build new technologies on top
of older technologies we're making
assumptions that every we're dependent
on we have to have technology this is
what really led to this talk because I
asked the question why does this even
exist
why is technology here why does it seem
like we're going so fast all of a sudden
if we look back the origins of
technology it's not just a human trait
we've got monkeys hitting nuts with
rocks and octopus carrying around a
coconut shell for shelter and the
example of an otter hitting clams on
Iraq this is technology it's the
application scientific knowledge for
practical purposes isn't it but we
humans tend to be a whole lot better at
it so we can build amazing things with
technology I'm not even gonna talk about
things we built I want to talk about the
one most important thing that I think
we've ever done with technology and it's
not going to be evidence the most
important thing we do we've done with
technology is we've been able to
transcribe information from biological
systems into non-biological systems we
can encode data into our physical world
this is the big deal we're talking about
the progression of information systems
here genes to brains to memes spreading
through our communities to
knowledge it gives us a way to write it
on to the world everywhere we're talking
about chiseling on stones inking on
papyrus scrolls printing books uploading
to the Internet all of that stuff it's a
new way of thinking about this but I
want to emphasize within genes
information is encoded directly into the
DNA brains give us information
accumulating over the lifespan of
organisms themselves memes let that
information flow between organisms and
through societies using brains as the
medium and then technology lets us store
all of this data in the nonliving world
and it leads us to where we are today
which is a big theme in this conference
and every other technology conference
pretty much we've got so much data we
don't know what to do with a lot of our
problems is how do we deal with this
data how do we persist it but how do we
understand it that's the big problem how
can we understand all this data how can
we move to the next stage what's after
Jean's brains means technology what's
the next thing I think it has something
to do with dealing with all this data if
this is the progression of information
systems we're accumulating all this
information what do we do with it so I
have a couple tactics and here's where I
got to the future of humanity
so first brain augmentation bear with me
here who does not have a mobile
computing device in their pocket that
can access all the public information in
the world one okay so this is an amazing
device this brain is an amazing device
this interface is not an amazing device
we're still relying on this clunky flesh
and bone interaction between our devices
and our minds and these devices are what
gives us access to all of our data our
money our music and movies are the
people that we love and then all these
other possible devices that we might
want to interact with that are going to
be hitting the market within the next
few years so we're trying to make this
less clunky
there's technologies like augmented
reality okay so it'll overlay data
overtop of something you're seeing
through a camera lens okay that's cool
but it sucks too so this is a little bit
better maybe maybe Google will make this
work and we get these glasses we can
wear and put data overlays on top of
what we're looking at that's pretty cool
that's a more efficient way to consume
data than through a screen that you're
just staring at all the time that'll
give us a way to look at the world
that's that's different
how many different things do you think
you could do if you had access to a
system like this how many different data
feeds could you feed into it it's
amazing there's two endless potential to
do this but how are we going to command
this device how are we going to tell it
measure from from that corner to that
corner are we going to use our voices
are we gonna type it we're gonna punch
it into something so we can get data to
us but we can't interact dynamically
with the data we can't ask it to load a
different overlay so why for my idea is
that we need to command by thought
here's what I want I want to be Johnny
March I want to be jacked in I want
science fiction I want all of this data
to be available to my brain without me
thinking too much about it so again it
you know Jeff Hawkins this morning
talked a bit about input into the brain
and how these are just data streams that
are flowing into the state this this
equivalent homogeneous structure so
we've already got some some feeds
millions of senses why not add some more
what's the problem with trying to format
our data in a way so that we can pick
the interesting feeds that we want to be
available to us and somehow give it
access to our brain so we can start
processing it it's not necessary that we
need to understand what we're doing the
baby the brain can learn what the
patterns that data are we don't know so
I know it seems far-fetched but we're
doing something similar technically your
device
so this is a woman's deaf born
profoundly deaf and her hearing is the
first time in her life here you can put
it down for a second just kinda makes me
happy watching how happy she is I mean
this is the this is good technology if
we're improving people's lives and this
relates exactly to what I'm talking
about the the technology that is used to
make her here again kind of hijacks the
input from her from her ear and
electronically processes it in a
processor embedded in just behind her
head behind her ear and then processes
it in some ways and then Rhian puts it
back in so we're already messing around
with the data that's going into our
brains why not create some new data
that's going into our brains
so that's tactic number one brain
augmentation tactic number two is a new
brain I told you this wasn't into Mensa
talk so I'm not gonna talk too much
about this but this is what we're
working on this is what we want to make
and we've been dreaming about this for a
really long time we need this we we've
got so much data and there's even
collectively we don't have enough brain
power to process it all data is
accumulating exponentially we're done
evolving relatively speaking we're done
evolving and the problem with this is
we've got a lot of problems to solve so
I propose we will create these systems
that understand the data all that we've
all the data we've encoded in our
environments and I argue that we must so
I think it's important because
technology's been great but technology
causes lots of problems as well so for
polluting our environment we're running
out of fossil fuels non-renewable
resources they're not going to be there
in the future where the ice caps are
melting
in sea levels are rising population
growth as of exploding just in the past
60 years our population is almost
tripled and you can tell it in some
areas of the world and the most
egregious thing is that we can't feed
all the human beings that we're
producing and the worst part is it's not
that we can't it's that we don't
collectively have the motivation to then
there's always the sword of damocles
self-destruction that might happen at
any time so we must solve these problems
and I think that this the future of
humanity and and the problems that that
we people here in this room are working
on could help solve those problems what
are you working on we all need to
collectively think on a grand scale when
we make big decisions when we make small
decisions we need to think big is this
good for Humanity as a whole what I'm
doing right now it's a good question to
ask and I think we also need to live
more on the edge I don't mean like take
up squirrel diving or whatever those
wingsuits guys do I mean are you
comfortable in your day job is it easy
to go to work and come home you're doing
it wrong live on the edge means
challenge yourself it means find hard
problems and attempt to solve them what
are your frontiers I've already
explained some of the frontiers of
science
what are your frontiers why aren't you
out there embracing that and trying to
discover those you could improve
humanity because in the end you and I
were all explorers suspended in space
and time in this tiny little planet in
an infinite world and discovery is our
only option so I encourage you to go out
there find these beautiful patterns make
them your own and share them with the
rest of the world I would like to
mention a few influential people to me
especially to this talk Stephen Wolfram
Richard Dawkins
Ray Kurzweil Jeff Hawkins Neil Tyson de
Grasse and Grace Hopper and then there's
Carl Sagan who's just my personal hero
so I'd like to thank these people living
or dead thank you
[Applause]